vous redonne salamé vous êtes
universitaire ancien diplomate grand
témoin de ce journal merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de france24 hassan
sallam et vous avez vécu plusieurs
grands conflits ces dernières années
vous avez même été un temps émissaire
spécial pour la libye quel regard vous
portez sur cette guerre en cours en
ukraine je pense que depuis une
quinzaine d'années on a vu que la
dérégulation de la force devenue la
règle après la fin de la guerre froide
on pensait que on allait tous accepté le
droit international n'a vu pour la
libération du koweït tout les noms
puissance entendre on l'a vu aussi au
lendemain les attaques du 11 septembre
une espèce de sens de communauté
internationale et puis tout s'est brisé
et s'est brisé probablement dans la
deuxième guerre d'irak en 2003 lorsque
la plus grande des puissances est allé
en irak sans légitimation sans même
l'appui de ses alliés étaient sans
résolution les coureurs et depuis et
bien il y a une espèce de
déréglementation de la force qui compte
à un peu de force va l'utiliser en
tournant le dos au conseil de sécurité
en oubliant le droit international en
violant la souveraineté de pays voisins
en en broyant demerson a même survolé
mission l'évoquent même si on ne
revendiquons la vie de ce droit
international lorsque je suis ferme les
autres je sais je sais
les russes étaient en première ligne
vous critiquez les américains en 2003
lorsqu'ils ont attaqué l'irak sans
raison légitime et bien aujourd'hui il
faut un peu la même chose c'est-à-dire
les attaques un pays voisin
sans qu'on comprenne exactement quelles
sont les motivations et sans une raison
légitime tout à fait et le vote de
l'assemblée générale destinée à montrer
que une bonne partie du monde où des
états du monde ne sont pas d'accord avec
cette attaque contre contre l'ukraine
donc j'espère que cette guerre ouvrira
les yeux que nous allons vers une espèce
de 2
de force qui ne sont plus gérés qui ne
sont plus contenue et que les grandes
puissances doivent donner l'exemple de
puissance plus petites allées puissance
moyenne de ne pas violer la souveraineté
des autres pays parce que si je vous
suis bien mais plutôt dans une logique
de la loi du plus fort on est dans cette
logique là depuis la guerre contre
l'irak on est entré dans cette logique
là et on a vu la lui si on avait la
chine
elle seule et taïwan on a vu la turquie
envoyé des mercenaires en libye on l'a
vu l'iran agir dans plusieurs pays de la
région et se vanter même de voir son
contrôle sur les capitales autre que la
sienne donc on voit que si les grandes
puissances n'agissent pas dans un
certain respect il y à un phénomène
d'émulation qui arrive une émulation en
chaîne est de plus en plus de pays
utilisent leurs moyens militaires
s'ingère dans des conflits qui ne sont
pas les leurs vont violer la
souveraineté dans l'autre pays et envoie
les mercenaires dans notre pays et les
grandes puissances ont une
responsabilité historique a donné
l'exemple et non pas seulement à donner
le mauvais exemple c'est l'ordre
occidental qui est en train de
s'effriter c'est ce que vous disiez
l'occidentale qui que l'on pensait créer
après la fin de la guerre froide oui et
il s'est effrité aussi par l'action des
états unis et pas uniquement par
l'action des adversaires de l'occident
aujourd'hui l'occident
a une chance
de pousser à l'extrême dans la sphère
chrétienne ou au contraire d'aider les
ukrainiens autant que faire se peut à
trouver un modus vivendi avec le voisin
russe parce que la géographie ne va pas
changer les ukrainiens vont devoir
toujours vivre à côté les russes et il
faudra les aider non seulement à
résister malines et notre fils je crois
qu'après onze jaune dans le combat
féroce deux millions deux millions de
réfugiés dans les pays voisins plus de
la moitié en polonais avec une
infrastructure détruite à plus de 10
milliards selon les estimations des
autorités ukrainiennes avec une montée
en flèche des prix du pétrole du gaz
blé etc il est temps de commencer à
penser une sortie de crise ils paient
pas conditions parce que vous dites les
occidentaux mais qu'ils les américains
et les européens ils parlent pas
toujours du même voyage non elle ne
parle pas d'une même voix et ne parle
pas d'une même voix la vision américaine
est quand même une vision d'un état
continent mais d'une continent il c'est
à dire s'est il tout se passe très très
loin de lui pour l'europe il s'agit de
voisinage le voisinage immédiat et on
pense que si c'est aujourd'hui le grain
de la peau est alors la vie ou la
géorgie voir notre pays menace aux
portes de l'europe voilà conserver les
américains ont une vision beaucoup plus
stratégique et leur volonté de contenir
la russie est peut-être plus grande que
leur volonté d'aider l'ukraine en ce
sens que ils se voient dans une espèce
de compétition
avec la russie où ils ne veulent pas que
la russie reprenne le rôle qui fut le
sien le temps où elle était union
soviétique
les européens ont une vision qui a une
vision de voisinage
une peur à la fois que le droit
international soit bafouée au coeur même
de l'europe mais ils sont conscients par
ailleurs que la russie est une grande
puissance qu'elle faisait partie du
concert des nations au 19e siècle et
qu'elle fera aussi partie du concert des
nations européennes au 20e siècle ça
veut dire que les européens doivent
faire cavalier seul ça veut dire qu'il
faut que les européens essaient d'être
plutôt de plus aligné forcément sur les
etats-unis de prendre leur propre
décision d'imposer leur propre rythme
leurs propres impôts est pas être
clairement pour le dire franchement pas
manipulés qu'ils sont fait manipuler
tout raté les européens réagissent
relativement bien
d'un côté il est d écrire
on peut lever humanitaire et même
militaires de l'autre ils tiennent et
appel
les règles qui sont en train d'être
violé l'une après l'autre mais aussi ils
gardent ils maintiennent le contact avec
goûter et je crois que que ce soit pour
le président français aux pulsions c'est
les allemands et pour d'autres ils
savent bien que la russie est aussi en
europe et qu'il faut maintenir ce lien
parce qu'il va y avoir un jour où il
faut trouver une solution
c'est à dire un compromis c'est-à-dire
des concessions de part et d'autre à ce
conflit qui a éclaté et ce jour là les
européens peuvent venir avec leur idée
pour tenter de trouver cette solution
je suis de ceux qui pensent
que le temps arrive que ne sont plus
loin du moment où il faut penser à une
sortie de crise et que les 12 ou qui
sont passées on fait déjà assez de mal
alors le pire n'est pas encore un avenir
vous pour le piller son corps évitable
mais à condition qu'on met sur la table
des voies de sortie qui ne soit pas
extrême qu'on comprenne que les russes
comprennent d'abord qu'ils ne peuvent
pas atteindre nos objectifs les plus
extrêmes mais que les ukrainiens
comprennent qu'ils peuvent intervenir au
risque de gagner mais qu'il ne peut pas
gagner en fonction de rapports de force
qui les oppose aux est aussi que les
autres pays comprennent que les dégâts
collatéraux qui ont frappé l'économie
internationale sont soutenables pendant
un mois ou deux mais pas indéfiniment et
ce alors que la maturité de 7 watts
sauter sera clair pour tous les yeux et
on l'espère merci beaucoup à sa salle